I want to start with the start of the
movie because there's a very intentional
choice that you guys make as filmmakers
about a saying we know how the story is
going to end it's not going to end well
but also it's going to be funny weird
there's gonna be this phone call that's
going to kind of set the tone for the
foam when you first got this script was
that already there was that part of what
you saw on Chris's story that it was
going to be both sad and happy and funny
at the same time absolutely there was
that was always going to be the first
scene and I that's what kind of stood
out to we heard adam scott my husband
and I are business partners and we had
gone the script and we were intrigued by
the fact that it was a writer at SNL a
senior writer at SNL wrote it and then
we read that script and that first scene
just hit hit us real hard so totally
it's such a challenge to make a movie
like this and I think that was maybe the
number one reason we wanted to jump on
board and we were so lucky that it came
our way Molly this is obviously a very
personal story to your writer director
Chris Kelly and it's based largely it's
not documentaries based largely on his
own mom and those very first
conversations you have with Chris what
were the important things that he wanted
you to know and what were the important
things that you wanted to know about how
you could create this character that
wasn't going to be a mirror of his mom I
think that he really um guided me
through her values like what was
important to her and kind of what she
what her take on was when she got sick
kind of her attitude her humor her
toughness her yeah her values we just
talked about everything and I was very
worried about you know some of the
scenes because it's kind of all over the
map we shot all over the over the place
and some some of the scenes she's really
sick something she's on chemo sent some
scene she's off kima so he really said
I'll help guide you because I can tell
you you know what the level is and if
you want me to write write it in the
scene like she's you know in terms of
sickness and health she's like you know
three or a ten so he really helped me
with that and then I also talked to his
MA
mom's best friend for a couple hours to
really get a sense of her from a
girlfriends point of view some stuff
that Chris might not be able to tell me
and that was really helpful so I did
stuff stuff like that but he also you
know it's not it's um
semi-autobiographical so we wanted to be
clear like this is not some documentary
that we're recreating exact moments but
just getting an essence of her element
asked a little bit about the look
especially for Marley about what you're
working with what kind of reference
you're using and maybe the difference
between being sick with cancer and being
sick from the treatments for cancer yeah
I think the biggest thing Chris really
wanted us to focus on was references
from his actual mother and he showed us
photos kind of not super close to the
end but kind of when she was going
through chemo and when she was off chemo
and just sick from cancer and those are
really important for Chris to have
differentiated in this in the movie
because we want to show when you first
go off chemo it's like you have an
uptick where it's like it looks like
you're getting better and then it kind
of goes back down again so we really
wanted to differentiate between the two
so that people knew like okay she's on
chemo and it's making her ill the
throwing up so we really tried to focus
on was her skin color cuz that's huge
when you're sick from chemo it's like
very yellow and then when you're sick
from cancer it's more of kind of a gray
like dull tone so we really wanted to
not make it look like she was wearing a
ton of makeup like this was just a
natural thing that was happening kind of
underneath and having those references
from Chris's mom were super super
important for us and what about Hera as
well the hair was a huge thing for Chris
because he wanted the length to be just
right he kind of broke down the script
for us in terms of sickness in months
versus days so when his mom first shaved
her head he wanted the growth to be like
just right so we had kind of two
distinct wigs it was a short wig and
long wig and it was kind of like the
length had changed and you could really
see the difference it was like he wanted
the natural gray to grow in just like
his mom had let happen and she didn't
dye her hair after it grew back so those
were really really important things
because it's such a
subtle but jarring like look when you
see someone who has gorgeous hair like
Molly and then all of a sudden she's got
short gray hair that could you know it
we actually use mens wigs to really kind
of cell that point Brian when you're
making a movie that is going to start
with the death but it's also going to be
filled with life and filled with humor
and a lot of comedy what does that
suggest to you in terms of look in terms
of lighting and the way in which you're
going to light scenes the way richer to
move the camera what were the
conversations you had with your with all
of these people and your writer-director
about what you're gonna do it was
Chris's first movie but he was he had
very clear ideas in his mind of what he
wanted it to feel like and I think the
main thing was he didn't want to over
dramatize or take the easy way out or be
a very harsh and manipulative with the
style of the movie so we really worked
out of a place of like taking what was
there using natural life using
practicals and supplementing to add
three dimensionality and had interest in
shape but really trying to be in the
moment and not have a lot of bells and
whistles it was pretty much exclusively
handheld camera really moving with the
cast and I think we didn't try and lean
too heavily into like let's make the
scene look horribly sad or really funny
we really just let rooms look like real
places and moved based on the actors and
tried to not have a lot of artifice
around it which is a really freeing way
to work and also a quick way to work
which was really helpful with how much
we had to do every day how did this
movie come together did you guys get
involved in the initial development and
how did the pieces all fall into place
that you were able to pull it off with
probably only a couple weeks of shooting
we Adam and I had gotten the script I
think about a year and a half before we
actually started shooting so we were
very early on we I don't think he
brought it out anywhere else we had a
mutual agent so we were blessed with
this script before many eyes had seen it
and our first task was really finding
finding David and Joanne and so Jesse
Plemons came on pretty early
to reading at he too this is his first
leading role which is kind of hard to
believe it was so different from
anything else he done that I think he
lept at the chance to do it and then and
then Molly came on board soon after and
I think we all thought we had a little
bit more time to prep but as things
happen right when we thought okay we'll
just start putting the feelers out and
and check in about financing it came
together very quickly so we had
officially three weeks of prep better
than three years of prep right better
i'm just waiting everything ok I think
we cast I don't see any reason why I
can't say this but I think we cast 32
parts in in a week and a half which I
mean I guess we just don't know any
better we had Alison Jones who helped us
tremendously with the casting but it was
kind of just like every every top choice
came through Adam told a story with June
Squibb obviously and Paul Dooley are
such great actors and do such great work
here but we talk we had a conversation
was it okay when June Squibb passes we
will go to who next and we just never
thought in a million years at June
Squibb would say yes and again she read
the script and told that a QA last night
she told her her agent I don't care what
I play in this I want to be in this
movie so Molly I want to ask you a
little bit about maybe the scene when
you read the script that you were
perhaps the most afraid of or the most
kind of focused on as you start filming
and then that did that turn out to be
the scene that was ultimately may be the
trickiest or was it something that you
hadn't expected oh yeah the scene that I
found was the hardest was the very end
when I'm really weak and I fall in the
shower and I feel embarrassed and then I
really want to let go and give up so
I've never done a scene like that before
so I was really worried about it and I
remember thinking god I'd I'd cried so
much during all the shooting that I was
like God I I don't know if I have it in
me but I remember it was so you know
she's so weak and she's leaning on so I
was really worried about that scene but
I am
so glad that it came out okay and you
know she's whispering she barely has a
voice so um I was really worried but
Jesse's so great and Chris really helped
me and he liked that it was quiet so I'm
so bad I came out okay when you watch
movie like this you certainly leave the
theater thinking about the people who
are important to you and their
relationship to you and what you need to
tell them were things you might have
said when you're making a movie like
this do you go through the same thing
Molly you're kind of nodding a little
bit yes I think I really thought about
my own mom and my father and their
values and you really do think so much
about your own children and I so many of
those thoughts flashed through my head
and still do and I just think about how
her life was cut short and you know
people's life who's cut short and what a
mother would do for anything just to buy
time to spend more time with her kids
just how a mother would fight to the end
of the earth for her children for her
family I deeply related to the material
o brien women yeah I mean I have two
small kids and it definitely made me I
don't know coming home every day after
making a movie like this which is was an
amazing opportunity but even more
draining than some I mean the days are
always long but I think we all just
cared even more about this movie and and
did such powerful work many days in a
row coming home it really made me just
appreciate how lucky I am to have my
family no it was actually kind of crazy
when I read the script because I had
dealt with issues of my mom's health and
whenever we'd shoot super late nights my
parents are on the East Coast so it was
kind of nice to be able to call them
like three in the morning my mom was up
at six getting ready for work and I
could just kind of talk to her about my
day and it was just nice that like you
know my mom had horrible health issues
and we almost lost her that I could
still have that relationship with her
and share these moments of I'm working
on this really really powerful movie and
it's just amazing that I can still make
this phone call at the end of the day to
like tell you about my day so it was
really really an amazing
experience to be a part of Naomi the
performance is in the film even when we
have seen it you know 50 60 70 times now
I all of them are fantastic but Molly
and Jesse just connect it made us
connect in so many ways just even
looking at a monitor I felt like I I was
lucky I had my husband on set every day
so we would have liked a little shorty I
just look at each other and we would
know like okay this is intense and it's
a wonderful experience to be in watching
these two people especially that last
scene where you really just see
yourselves as a as a son or a daughter
or as a parent it's hard not to connect
in any universal way thank you guys so
much and thank you guys for coming out